SPEAKER: In this
video, we're going
to take a look at the basic
elements of subscriptions
within Google Play
to better understand
how subscriptions work.
First, of course, there
is your app as well as
your app servers.
Then there is the Google Play
Store on Android and Google
Play server APIs.
The right column is built
by you, the developer.
The left column
represents Google Play.
These columns can
also be separated
by those elements on Android
and those elements on servers
so both you and Google have an
Android element and a server
element.
Now you know your app interacts
directly with your servers.
But what about how
you, the developer,
interact with Google Play?
On the Android level, this is
done through the Google Play
Billing Library.
On the cloud level,
communication
is done through the Google Play
Developer API and Google Cloud
Pub/Sub.
And those are the basic elements
of subscriptions on Play.
All of these components
work together
to allow you to have
subscriptions within your app.
For more information,
visit the link onscreen,
or check out our
other videos here.